[Música]
y vos te acordás como naciste
te acordás como cómo y dónde naciste
casi seguro en una sala de partos
estabas en un lugar calentito oscuro
silencioso
comenzó un trabajo de parto y saliste
'somos hasta un mundo desconocido
donde había mucha gente trabajando
muchas luces
mucho ruido eso es una sala de partos
el nacimiento para el bebé es muy
traumático
es la situación más difícil que tiene
que atravesar que la hemos atravesado
todos
y esa situación tan difícil hay una
separación también entre la mamá y el
bebé en el momento del parto es una
separación psico físico y espiritual
en vida de médica ginecóloga y obstetra
trabajé muchísimo y se parto cirugía
guardia consultorio hice todo
pero a mí me faltaba algo que yo no
sabía lo que era entonces empecé a
buscar e hice una introspección busque
algo muy profundo
a ver si me aparecía y entonces comencé
a hacer un montón de terapias terapias
energéticas transpersonales terapias
espirituales me fui a la india hice
meditación fue cuatro veces a la amazona
tomé plantas sagradas en fin y también
estudié medicina china
todo esto me llevó a mí a un proceso
interno donde pude vivir mi vida
intrauterina y recordarla no solo la
vida intrauterina sino también mi propio
nacimiento
cuando estaba en el útero de mi mamá me
sentí muy sola abandonada con muchísimo
miedo y con una sensación tremenda de
inestabilidad era terrible estar en ese
lugar y saben por qué
porque mi mamá había perdido a las
mellizas en el embarazo anterior que se
murieron y ella casi se murió
pero pasaron 3 o 4 años y quiso un
embarazo mi papá tenía terror mi mamá
quería un hijo y bueno esa hija soy yo
en mi casa de mi embarazo no se hablaba
no me tenían registrada
era mi papá tenía muchísimo miedo mi
mamá tenía miedo también y ese miedo me
lo transmitieron a mí yo lo hice propio
a ese miedo
y así viví dentro del útero
sola abandonada y con muchísimo miedo
llegó el momento del nacimiento
casi un mes antes
estaba cansada de estar en el útero
y
viene el parto yo fui 8 messina las
llevan a mi mamá a la sala de partos la
recibe el médico bueno se produce el
nacimiento muy rápido yo nací rapidísimo
el médico ve que estoy viva y dice me
deja y me deposita sobre una mesa blanca
y fría
y la silla atendiendo a mi mamá
a mí nadie me esperó ni me recibieron
con alegría
mi papá estaba expectante y mi mamá en
otro mundo
este es el segundo abandono que tuve
primero dentro del útero y el segundo
cuando el así que me descargan en esta
mesa sola
esto me dejó una marca un sello tan
importante en mi vida que para poder
salir tuve que salir de una manera
arrolladora
cuando fui grande elegir una profesión
donde siempre estoy alerta siempre estoy
lista me llamaban para un parto estaría
corriendo y así pasé la vida también a
mil por la vida ahora estoy un poquito
más tranquila
toda esta experiencia tan fuerte me
llevo a mí
a cambiar la manera de trabajar
la manera de hacer los partos y la
manera de vivir
primero dejé la cirugía después de que
la ecografía y me quedé con lo para los
partos y la parte clínica y recuerdo que
mis compañeros más allegados un día me
dijeron
silvia qué te pasa que lo mejor de tu
vida como médica estás dejando la
cirugía y la ecografía yo le dije no me
pasa nada
quiero trabajar distinto
no me entendieron
tuve mucha resistencia también a nivel
del hospital con mis colegas y con mis
colegas de la clínica pero tuve la
suerte de hacer varios seminarios y
retiros con el doctor michel odent
considerado a nivel mundial como el
padre del parto natural y el domicilio
porque porque él revalorizó el parto
natural en nuestras épocas a nivel
académico
este es el parto de nuestras abuelas el
parto de muchísimas todavía comunidades
que los que tienen este tipo de parto
y yo me sentí respaldada
y que el camino que había tomado era el
correcto
con mi nueva manera de trabajar con mi
nuevo paradigma
cuando llegaba una pareja a mi consulta
puedes estar embarazada o no lo primero
que yo trataba de mostrar y de contarle
lo importante que era la fecundación
desde la parte emocional cómo estaban
los papás si estaban alegres estaban
tristes y tenían proyectos si tenían
ganas de tener un bebé o no
porque toda esa emoción la siente el
bebé y la guarda como un recuerdo
prenatal
después los acompañó durante el embarazo
tras nueve meses y ahí también el bebé
graba todo
si en los nueve meses que pasamos dentro
del útero son más importantes que los 90
años que vivimos afuera
que el debe por nacer es un ser
consciente que siempre recuerda
eso lo puedo decir yo porque lo
experimenté por eso es tan importante
cuidar la parte emocional de todo el
parto embarazo todo completo a la mamá
después de ir el parto
el parto puede ser
en la clínica o en el hospital que ahora
se puede pedir un parto respetado
respetado humanizado a mí no me gusta
mucho el carmín humanizado pero bueno
pero sea se puede pedir este tipo de
parto
y el parto del domicilio
este es el que a mí me gusta y me siento
plena
en mis últimos años tuve la suerte de
hacer muchísimos partos en domicilio
acompañada por una pediatra y mi partera
formábamos un tipo maravilloso
y les puedo contar que nunca tuvimos
ningún problema
pero por qué porque estábamos muy bien
preparadas
la mamá estaba segura que quería tener
su hijo en su casa
que ella es la gran protagonista
y que sabía instintivamente cómo hacerlo
nosotros como equipo nos preparábamos
preparábamos el lugar nosotros nos damos
instrucciones no damos medicación no
damos órdenes nada el equipo acompaña la
seguridad y la confianza
la mamá puede tener un poquito de miedo
no porque es algo esperado pero para ese
momento y se está acá y tiene valor
seguridad y confianza en lo que está
haciendo
es así
yo si es necesario utilizo todo lo que
aprendí en mi vida y también la medicina
tradicional con todos los recursos
bueno sigue el momento del parto lo más
esperado
nos preparamos todo en la casa la mama
elige el lugar donde parir puede ser el
dormitorio el comedor el living el baño
ella busca su lugar en la casa
nosotros lo que pedimos que sea
calientito que el lugar esté calientito
y que nos podamos movilizar con
facilidad es lo único
puede haber aromas puede haber música
todo eso fue elegido durante el embarazo
pueden estar las mascotas pueden estar
los hermanitos todos pueden estar es así
en un ambiente muy armonioso y muy bien
cuidado
llegó el momento del parto
la mamá
comienza con sus contracciones y el bebé
comienza a tomar este mundo pero asoma
muy despacito
tan despacito que cuando asoma la
cabecita llora pero llora poquito
y cuando nosotros la ayudamos a la mamá
para colocar el bebé sobre el pecho
ahí
se funde la mamá y el bebé en un abrazo
interminable todo el tiempo que ellos
necesitan
yo o la persona que la mamá elija cortar
el cordón recién cuando deja de latir
y en ese en ese ambiente tan cálido
nosotros vemos cómo está el bebé cómo
está la mamá
y
con tanta felicidad tanta tranquilidad
tanto amor nosotros los dejamos
por supuesto después seguimos los
controles pero
es esa sensación cuando recibimos el
bebé en una carta es maravilloso
bueno esta experiencia
que terminó de contarles
es para mostrarle que hay otra manera de
nacer
y otra manera de vivir
que científicamente está demostrado que
todos los estudios que están hechos
sobre el estado emocional de la mamá
afecta el estado emocional del bebé no
solo el emocional sino también el mental
qué
lo que vivimos desde la fecundación el
embarazo y el parto nos deja a nosotros
una impronta en nuestra personalidad
para toda la vida
los invito a tomar conciencia que para
tener niños felices adultos felices y
una comunidad feliz la educación
emocional de nuestros hijos comienza en
el útero muchas gracias
[Aplausos]